the summer i turn pretty is my new
obsession i'm not even mincing words i'm
addicted my producer and i were texting
each other back and forth
we're like oh have you seen this episode
yet um
lola i do not believe
pardon what team are you on
oh
conrad come on now you know it's conrad
oh
conrad girl okay
what are other people saying um
yeah yeah i mean
i get it i get it what team are you guys
now i need to know
i'm team lola team belly
that was a good answer
well i do not believe that this is your
first acting gig
yeah i mean i was a big theater kid in
in high school and in college but i mean
this is my first profession
so wild i'm very grateful
so how did you react when you found out
you got the part like did you realize it
was going to be a huge deal
yeah i think um it's all started to hit
me a little more now as as we come
closer to please date two that it's not
just this you know little project that
we all worked on together last summer
it's really a big thing and it's kind of
you know beautiful that that so many
people get to see it and get to
experience it because it was special to
me in the past but um
yeah i was freaking out i called my mom
crying after work because i was at
school i was away at school so i um
i called her and we just sort of like
cried and celebrated
that is so exciting jenny once i found
out you know you were the brains behind
to all the buzz i've loved before i was
like oh this makes sense that's why this
is so good uh you know the trailer when
it first dropped it it now has five
million views obviously you know fans of
the books are so excited for this series
you've already been picked up for season
two and it hasn't even come out yet what
are you excited for all the fans to see
with this series
oh my gosh i'm excited um for them to
see
lola's beautiful performance as belly
i'm excited yeah
fall in love with her um i think that we
have such a beautiful cast
i would say i'm really excited for like
our fave like music moments
um i think the fans will be um
really satisfied by those
but just overall just to be
in for the journey
i love that there's such an innocence
about this series obviously it's a
coming-of-age story but something with
the summer and i know that tradition is
something that's explored a lot in this
series so i want to know what are some
of your favorite summer traditions
i really like going to italy in the
summer oh take me
take me
twice
i've done a couple times not really a
tradition it's just i really want to go
back yeah now i'm working on the show so
i can't
go anywhere that's true i'm sorry
i think back to that our new training
our new tradition our wonderful new
tradition that's exciting lola what
about you what are some of your favorite
memories or favorite summer traditions
yeah i mean i have uh i have some family
in sweden so i used to travel there with
my family and we haven't been going as
often because i'm a pandemic
trying to stay safe but that was always
something that i looked forward to
and then i mean now like you were saying
this is this new tradition of filming
being with my summer family we're about
to go back
it's true so knowing that you get to
work with the whole cast again does it
feel a little bit like summer camp
because you're shooting in the most
beautiful locations
yeah yeah no it's it's incredible and it
kind of does because we've all become
such close friends and um
have this real life bond and this real
life love for each other so it it's like
the most fun to be able to get to do
what we love and do it again
i love that what's your favorite thing
about playing belly why do you think
she's a character that readers have
connected with so much and obviously
viewers will as well
i think she's very relatable she's um
you know a teenage girl who's
experiencing first love and first
heartbreak and
this summer of change in her
relationships and within herself and um
feeling like she wants to you know sort
of become her own independent person to
find herself and that's something that's
extremely relatable for for me who i'm
you know i'm still figuring so yeah
myself and i think
um it's such a beautiful thing to watch
and to watch her just experience all of
these emotions to like
the fullest and not not
mock that but to really uh represent
that and and and feel
um
feel like
it just feels very real and
that i could definitely relate to that
as a 16 year old and now it's a 19 year
old
i love that jenny you are the queen of
coming of age stories i i'll literally
watch anything you're a part of so i'm
so excited for everyone to see this
so much
thank you i want to come to italy with
you please
[Laughter]
that's amazing
you